a new app called the list is as simple
as it sounds it lets you create lists
and read those other users make and
while that might make it sound like more
of a productivity and planning app the
people who are using it make it far more
interesting than that the list was made
by BJ Novak who's best known for playing
Ryan on the office Novak celebrity has
brought with it other famous types who
are using the list to make their own
lists ina garten Lena Dunham Katie
Couric snoop and Mindy Kaling are just a
few of the stars who are making lists
like best weeknight dinners favorite
herbs and exotic pets I want some of the
list contain photos and others are full
of inside jokes some of them are
crowd-sourced meaning you can contribute
to a list someone else made or ask
everyone to give input to yours for
instance if you're traveling and want a
list of the best coffee shops in Austin
or maybe you're bored and want users to
recommend Netflix titles and if nothing
else the list is a little peek into
celebrities minds
you